take me back you guys get hit by the
feds for
essentially the the mixtape hustle yeah
for people who don't know back in the
day I don't even know how many CD
burners you guys had to have had
but I know that you have been the name
bootle no I only had one of the ten the
ten ones yeah so you put the one at the
top and then you do ten at a time and
then had a little shitty printer I was
printing [__] mixtape covers out on I
would go to the [__] Staples and buy
the jewel cases I'd steal ink from the
[__] demo printers what a time but
you know how much money you think I made
you oh you made me a lot of money you
have to feed my baby oh I would say you
you DJ Smalls the game and G-Unit radios
that was that was I mean because
Southern Smoke was like a big brand to
it very very big brand very big that was
my main competitor yeah it was like
gangster girls in Southern Smoke yup
yeah but but like do you know like what
the like was there like a certain thing
that happened that turned the fed's
attention to what was happening with
mixtape culture because technically
technically it was against the law I
guess yeah it was it was against the law
like what was the Catalyst I guess that
turned
I mean there's a lot of different
conspiracy theories I mean if if you if
we go back in in time like if we look at
where music was at that time like the
music business was
in a decline for sure so a lot of like
the bottom line wasn't
what they the heads or you know the top
of the food chains were used to seeing
and mixtapes were it was like the Wawa
West in a lot of ways it was such it was
CR it was like the crypto market so
outside of like the sanction gangster
grills that I was doing and the other
like Junior radios there were like all
these just random mixtapes out of people
getting songs and leaking them and
taking them from gmails and you know
literally being bootlegs so I think in a
way it was affecting
um potentially it could have been
affecting some of the business or maybe
they were just looking at mixtapes as a
scapegoat you know and then you know at
the same time mixtape started to show up
in like Best Buy and Target which I
never understood yeah she was like [__]
those are [__] bootlegs like
literally like they had barcodes on them
and that that wasn't coming for me you
know what I mean like so they didn't run
up in Best Buy with the M16s and arrest
them for bootleg in a racketeering but I
think when when that started to happen
and like you know me being the the go-to
guy like the top of the food chain it
was like you know maybe they were out to
send a message and and obviously it got
across because [__] changed after that
for sure so at the time in your Peak you
guys have your headquarters are you guys
burning the CDs Distributing the
mixtapes to like the bodegas the mixed
units of the world these websites where
you can go get mixtapes were you guys
the source of just your gangster girl
[__] or were you guys also producing
other people's shoes nah we were just
doing all in-house stuff so it was all
Affiliates all Affiliates yeah so
everything that we were doing was
strictly like under our under our brand
um so there were gangster girls but like
that was one of the problems too like so
when when when they went to
gangstergirls.com
one of the red flags that they saw
wasn't necessarily the gangster grills
it was the other CDs that had like
Michael Jackson on the cover yeah or
Beyonce on the cover yeah and it was
like a blend of Michael Jackson so
mashup [__] yeah where there was like
the radio mixes yeah they seen [__] like
that and like oh these are like you know
there's Michael Jackson and what were
you guys selling mixtapes per piece for
back then like let's say if someone
bought it directly from you maybe like
two three dollars oh wow I used to do I
think five bucks a pop or five for 20.
for wholesale no no just like at the
swap meet in my space Oh I'm talking
about Jose Jose I was doing like 250
yeah like 253 dollars
um a piece probably like
seven eight dollars or something like
that I don't I don't remember everything
I was doing at that time was in bulk so
we were it was all wholesale [__] yeah
it was at a lesser price people were
buying like
quantities of from 200 to a thousand at
the time like non-stop in a hypothetical
World in which you were doing that but
you're not who you are right now what
would have been the best year that you
made mixtape money wise in a
hypothetical world where it actually
didn't happen
and far Universe far away
are you so let me get this question
straight I'm not I'm asking you if you
were someone who looks just like you in
a different Universe how much illegal
mixtape money would somebody like you
have made at a peak without it actually
being you
know what's crazy to answer that like
and then hypothetical World somebody who
may have looked like me like in like
another Universe doppelganger like a
hundred thousand a month wow yeah and
that is that taxable
hypothetical world where this person
some of it is yeah I was it was a a
hypothetical person would have been
paying taxes on it because it was gone
through the banking system it was Cash
involved as well yeah but what's crazy
is even after the raid like during the
like that pith era and live mixtape era
yo I probably made more money than how
because they were they were cutting me
checks
to make whatever gangster girls I put
out exclusive to their site so when an
artist would come to me to do a tape I'd
be like that's fine but it has to go on
that Biff and then that piff was what
was the Gap hip check for like for
dedication what was the check probably
like 50. geez they would give me they
gave me 50 and gave Wayne a buck 50.
like and yo when you guys would drop
those [__] tapes like [__] like that
people get shut the [__] crash like I I
made more money after the raid off
mixtapes than I made during the earlier
days I bought uh the first time I ever
interviewed you or met you I was like a
nobody intern of power in Phoenix and I
had to I bought the white tea which I'll
never forget DJ Drama [__] off a mixed
unit and I was like man I'm about to be
drunk I'm about to bust out the tea that
was and and we did that interview like
during my first album run right after
the raid so that was like 07. yeah it
was around it was it was early bro I was
like a nobody yeah but I never forget
like I remember you from that time I was
like a skinny the first time we met in
in Phoenix when we did that [__]
triple XL DJ Drama tea yeah shout out to
mix unit man I used to buy a hell of
shirts off of there yeah they had
everything yeah [__] amen I just saw
well I guess DatPiff isn't actually a
closing they put up a tweet that said
that they're reading I saw that I was so
sad that's crazy I mean it's crazy
because Fab dm'd it to me too like I had
I think I I saw it on
um I saw a post about it and then right
after I saw a post about it Fab dm'd it
to me and I think he dm'd it to me
because I we just recently sat down for
um something I got coming out and we
were talking about that era but like
just to think about that like imagine if
DatPiff does or did had gone under like
that's like a generation yeah it's like
it's like a part of our culture that
could potentially go like lost you know
what I mean like so much of that stuff
is not available on the dsps and like
you know where people don't know where
to find it and like if we lose if we
lose that you know that time or and that
music from that that era it's like
it'll just be like a word it'll be like
damn do you remember or you know it'll
it'll just be spoken about so it's
really it's like really important that
we we get a hold of that you know just
just to keep it alive
got to keep the history where else am I
gonna go I don't want to go listen to
some shitty YouTube [__] [__] to go
listen to like the Pharrell tape or some
little brother
and one of my goals is something I've
been working on too is definitely
bringing some of the classics to the
dsps like so they they uh can be
available so people you know there's so
many projects like and it's a lot of
work but it can be done like it can be
done so
um one that we're definitely in the
process of working on is is getting
dedication to up on dsps it's really
just what clearing the Beats yeah
clearing the pub clearing the Beats like
you know I'm sure Wayne's down of course
yeah yeah yeah that can't do it without
without the gun can't do it without him